今日は法則の二番目ですね
まあ三種類ありますからね
因縁の法則とかとか 因と縁という二つありますね
で 初期仏教では因と縁というのはそんなに区別して考えてなかったんで
ただ因縁ですよという感じでね
ですから 因と縁というのはそんなにこの厳密に区別する必要あるかということを考えてはなかったし
まあそれなりに理解しておけばよろしかったんですね
で 何しろこの自分が修行によって自分の体を持って
心の働き 体の働きを自分で体験して
心の煩悩というもの 心の汚れというもの
そういうものを明確に見ていく過程でしたから
ですから 無常というものはいた簡単に感じられるものであるし
心の固定概念 えっと いろいろいろんな先入観
そういうものは消えていって
心はオープンになればなるほど無常が見えるはずなんですね
ですから 無常というものはとても簡単に感じられますしね
ですから その悟りに出る人には全然関係
そんなに影響あるわけじゃないんです
厳密に因と縁となんですかと分けなくても
で パーリ語で因と縁というのは HETU
それからPACCEという HETU PACCE
という言葉二つありますね
で 拠点ではHETU PACCE
というのはほとんど同義語でいつでも一緒に使っちゃうんですね
例えば皆様方 今今まで勉強したことを無明によって行が生じるという十二項目の因果法則がありますね
その場合はPACCEという言葉を使ってますね AVIJJA
PACCE SANKHARA SANKHARA
PACCE VIGNANA
ですから この 原因 因という意味で使ってるんです
ですから 全く区別を考えていなかったと
と思った方がいいんだよ
お釈迦様の時代では 時々何かの原因は何ですかと聞く場合は KOHETU
KO PACCEYO HETU
は何ですか？PACCEは何ですか？と質問するんですね
そういうふうな場合は
じゃあ二つに分けてるんではないかと
じゃなくて それは単なる同義語でね
例えばKOHETU KO
PACCEYO HETU HETU
は何ですか？PACCEは何ですか？とそこで続くんですね
文章は 例えばSANKHARANA UPADAY SANKHARA
行が生れるためには何がHETUで何がPACCEですか？そこでAVIJJAEVA HETU AVIJJA PA
CCE SANKHARA UPAJJANTI
と言うんですね AVIJJA
がHETUでAVIJJAがPACCEでSANKHARAが生まれるんだというふうな答えですから
結局HETU それからPACCEというのは拠点では
初期仏教ではまあ区別しないで同じ意味で考えていたんです
で 今まで私は何言ってるか
なかなかわからないかもしれません
だけど これからの説明に入るとまあわかると思います
アビダンマになるとHETUとPACCEっていうのは全く二つなんですね HETU
とPACCEと二つになって HETU
は因と訳されているし PACCE
は縁と解訳されているんですね
因 縁 そこで因というのはまあ原因であって
まあ英語で書くならばCause
あるいはまあReason Reason
といえばちょっとあの
まあちょっと英語の単語としては幅広く使ってますからね
他の言葉ありますか で PACCE
の場合は英語で書けばConditionですね
そういうふうに だからその言葉を見ると全く二つの意味なんですね Cause
というのは原因であって Condition
というのは原因ではないんですね
条件なんですね ですから原因と条件
というふうな二つの意味で考えているんですね
それはアビダンマの世界です
そこで 十二因縁の場合はパーリ語ではアヴィッジャパッチヤとパッチヤという言葉を使っているのに
アビダルマになるとアヴィッジャ
へーとでサンカーラが生まれるんだと
というふうになっているんですね
アヴィッジャパッチヤでサンカーラが生まれるんじゃなくて
アヴィッジャというへーとでサンカーラというものごとが生まれるんだと
そうすると アヴィッジャとサンカーラの間にパッチヤ
またサラに入れなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
だから経典から見ると
アヴィッジャパッチヤサンカーラ
アヴィッジャによってサンカーラが生まれる
アビダルマになるとアヴィッジャの原因でサンカーラが生まれる
それでアヴィッジャとサンカーラ
アヴィッジャがサンカーラを生み出すまた条件もありますと
それで区別わかりますかね
経典ではアヴィッジャによってサンカーラが生まれた
それだけ アビダルマになると
アヴィッジャのアヴィッジャという原因でサンカーラが生まれる
それでアヴィッジャという原因がある条件によってサンカーラが生まれると
そこで原因はアヴィッジャであって
また条件は別なものになるんですね
いわゆるこの原因はどんな条件でサンカーラが生み出すかというふうに 2つに明確に分けて分けるんですね
で それはアビダンマの発展させた人々の
まあ随分勝手な乱暴な考え方でもないんですけどね
なぜかというと まあまあ
じわじわとこの原因の論理をね
まあ研究していくと いろいろそういうものはできてきていったんじゃないかなと
とにかくこの条件論入ったところで
アビダンマってのはすごい難しくなってしまったんです
で 結局難しくなったんだけど
明確に見るととても簡単なことなんですが
アビダンマの 7つのテキストがありますね
アビダンマのテキストは
その 7つのテキストの中で一番大きくて
一番分かりにくくて読みに読みにくいものは
この原因論なんですね
パッターナパカラナという本なんですけど
そちらには原因じゃなくて条件
条件の分析 ただそれだけ
ものすごい大きいんです
本が 例えばアビダンマの 1番目の本はダンマサンガニという法の分析なんですね
それはかなり経典に近いんです
それ小さいんです テキストは
それで分析論という本がありまして
その分析論も小さくてわかりやすい
その中では経典の分析
アビダンマの分析と明確にアビダルマ的な分析
経典の分析と分けているんですね
アビダンマにパッターナすってない
それから人格の分析という本がありましてね
分析とは言えないね 人格のなんとかパンニャティですね
いろんな人々をいろいろカテゴリーに入れる
そういうのはまあそんなに読みやすいわけじゃないんだが
アビダンマだからね でもまあちょっと仏教用語を身について読もうとすれば読めないわけでもないんです
パッターナになると 何言ってるかさっぱりわからないほど難しくて
ややこしくてということになったんです
そういうわけで 仏教の世界ではパッターナこそがとても難しくて大変ありがたいと
難しければありがたいというくだらない考え方は昔もあったんです
真理は難しいというのはまた別な話で
理解しがたいというのは別な話で
理解しがたいんだからありがたいっていうのは馬鹿げたな話です
真理は理解しがたいというならば
それは事実であるならば
それはしょうがないんであって
難しいんだから大変ありがたい
それは全く意味のある言葉ではないんですね
では 今日は説明に行きます
テキストの 243 ページの 2番目なんですが
いわゆる 14 という項目に入っています
そこでパーリ語でパッターナナヤという言葉がありますね
そのパッターナナヤというのは
パッターナというのはこのテキストの名前なんですね
アビダンマの 7番目のテキストの名前なんですね
そのパッターナというテキストに出てくるナヤっていうのは方法という意味なんですね
で パッターナという言葉はもうちょっと
分析してみましょう あまり別にわからなくても構いません
大して意味がありません
パッターナという言葉で
そういうことはなかなか日本訳はしにくいんですし
それはこのパーリ語から見ると
このパティという言葉と
このタハという動詞トゥートとか言うんですね
これは動詞なんですね
パティっていうのはプレフィックスで
いろんな意味でプレフィックス作っちゃうんです
これからできるとですね
パティという言葉とタハという言葉
タハというのは動詞ですから
タハというのはあるという意味なんですね
いるという意味なんですね
立てる 成り立つという
なるという意味でもいいんですね
私はここにいますということはパーリ語でいえば
タハという言葉使えるんですね
アハンイダティッタハミと
パーリ語でいえば イダっていうのはここにティッタハミというのはいますということで
それから置くという場合
例えば生命ないものはね
ペンを置きますという場合はタペティ
タハという言葉を使っちゃうんですね
ですから いるという意味でいる
あるという そこら辺で意味が変わるんですね
一応いるといえば 存在的に私がいる
人がいると動物がいるということになりますけど
それよりはこの物理的にあるという風な方にちょっと言ってるんですね
それからこのタハという言葉にパという
パというプレフィックス入れるとパッハティという動詞が出てくるんですね
その場合は実際にパーリ語を知らないと色々例出したって意味がないんだけど
何かこの論理的に成立するという意味になっちゃうんですね
まあこういうわけで こういうことで
こういうことでこうなりますよということは
論理的に合理的に話を進めていって
考え方進んでいって決まるんですね
結論出すですね 結論作るという意味でパというパですね
パという プレフィックス入れちゃうんですね
動詞は同じ動詞なんです
それからあの いろんなものを考えたら
こういうこういうことを考えたら
あなたはどう思いますか？と
あなたに何が浮かぶですか？と質問する場合は
私は相手の結論を聞いてるんですね
例えばお金のために悲壮でも人に飲ませるんだと
で こういうこういう事実があるんだと
あなたどう思いますか
そんなことはというと
その人の結論 その情報について提供した情報について相手の結論を聞いているわけなんです
あんたどう思いますかというのは
そういうことなんですね
その場合はパーリ語でターの前にウパという
ウパというプレフィックス入れちゃうんですね
でも実際にどんな言葉で使っているか
ちょっと省きますけど
それとアビダンマの説明と違いますから
それは言語学になりますからね
で だから自分の意見 いろいろ情報について自分の意見を言う場合は
ウパというプレフィックス使って動詞は同じ
で そのその使い方によって動詞変化がありますからね
その変化によって だから見たところでは
この言葉さっぱりわからないと思うかもしれませんだけど
こうやって分析してみれば
ウパがあってターがあって
こういう変化ですからということで理解しやすいんです
ですから このインドの言葉を勉強する人々は
大体動詞をまず勉強してみちゃうんですね
それから動詞に何が頭の方につけるかと
それで動詞はどのように変化するかで
サンスクリット語で動詞は種しかないし
種類の変化は決まってるし
動詞のリストっていうのはそれほどたくさんないんです
それで それに前につけるプレフィックスというのは種類しかないんですね
かかどちらか数が決まってるんです
ですから その組み合わせでもう膨大なんです
学者はいろんなことを喋ってるんです
ですから 言語としてはそれほど勉強しにくい
難しいということでもないんです
まだあえてもうとっくに死んでる言語だから
さらに勉強っていうのはしやすいんですね
いわゆる新しい変化はないんだから
じゃあそういう風にこのパティとター
本当はこのパーリ語でこのプレフィックス書くのは学者はしません
パーリ語はよりはこのサンスクリット語を使うんですね
サンスクリット語はより人工的な言葉なんです
誰も使ってはなかったんだけど
それは完全に人工語なんです
人工語ですけど インドに使っていた言葉から似ている
このアーリア言語ですから
そのアーリア言語家族の様々な言語から基本的な誰にでも共通しているところを選んで
このお釈迦様が現れる前に
紀元 6 世紀でこのサンスクリットの文法書を書いてしまったんで
パニニという人が いまだにサンスクリット語で使っている文法書はパニニのテキストなんです
だからすごい人なんです
で サンスクリット語で本当は書かないといけないので
サンスクリット語で書くとこちらはpratiとなります
これはsthaという風になります
そこではこのpati-tha-あるいはprati-stha-というstha-は動詞 prati-
は これはパーリ語でpatiサンスクリット語でprati
それだけの差ですね で
なんでpratiとしていますかというと
この実際に使っているパーリ語やら
またたくさんありますね
同じ言語家族の中でいっぱいいろんな言語があるだこうだとかね
その実際に使っている言語などいろいろ変化が起こるんですね
その変化は元はpratiというふうにしておけば
この変化の理解しやすいんです
まあそういうことなんですけども
じゃあそれでpratiというどういう意味かというと
あの 何かに関わりがあるということなんですね
何に対してという意味なんですね
何かに対して 何かに対して関わりがあるという意味のprefixなんですね stha-
というのはやっぱりいるということだから
成り立つということですね
ですから 何かに関係があって成り立つということになるんです
関わりがあって成り立つと
いわゆる現代我々知っている言葉で言えば
相対的になり立つという相対性なんですね
で それだったら相対的だから
まあ結局因果法則そのものですからね
原因といっても同じことで
そんなに厳密に区別しなくてもいいんですけどね
とにかく関わりがあって成立する
その関わりがなかったら成立はしませんという相対的なこと
相対的な立場を意味しているんですね
それでこの原因があって結果が生まれる
ヘトゥとファラがあります
これからアビダンマの説明なんですけど
ヘトゥというものがありまして
ヘトゥは原因 それにはファラ
果が生まれるんですね
結果が ヘトゥとファラ
そこでこの原因が ヘトゥがファラを作る
果を作る 原因は果を作る
それで原因がどんな条件の中で果を作るかということはパッチェの説明なんですね
で 今まで説明したのは原因と果の流れだけ
中に で 今日は説明しようとしているのは
この原因がどのような条件の中で果を作るかということですね
ですから 条件という意味でパッチェという言葉を使っているんですね
漢訳では縁でありますからね
因と縁の だから因と縁と果になっちゃうんですね
それからこの じゃあ条件というと
すごくもう言いにくいことで
難しいことで その場でその場で考えなくちゃいけないものになっちゃうんですけど
それまたわかりやすく
条件は 二十四しかないんだと
二十四にしているんですね
だから 二十四の条件がありまして
その条件の種類が 二十四種類ありまして
そのいくつか揃ったら結果が出ますよということです
ですから あの チャトゥーヴィーサティパッキャという言葉は一般的にパーリ語で使ってますね
チャトゥーヴィーサティというのは二十四
パッキャ 条件は二十四ですよと
でもさらにこちらである二十四のリストを勉強してみると
あ 二十四がないと 二十四がないんです
そちらには かなり同じことをダブってるんですね
ですから本当は二十四はないんですが
それから勉強するとわかると思います
二十四のリストは全部言いますけど
まあ論理的にまとめてみると二十四がないということはわかるんです
でもアビダンマの先生たちがそれを二十四に何かそういう風に私が言うように
何かちょっとからかって何か言っちゃうと
ものすごくもう すごく批判するんです
これこそ素晴らしい教えだと
立ち触るなと もうあの
あの 今まで勉強したところでは同じ言葉ダブっていたってことは経典でも出ているんで
例えばサティは力でもあるし
根でもあるし いろんなカテゴリーに入る
その場合はやっぱり実践的な立場で働きが違うということで
そういう風にダブってダブって
まあリピートされてリピートされてしていたんですけど
それはまあ それはそれで意味があるんですね
この場合は意味があるかないか
ちょっと考えなくちゃいけないんですね
で 言えるのはやっぱりまああっちこっちからいろいろ条件考えて考えてリスト作ったんであって
それをリストまたまたまたよくよく考えて
きちんとぴったししたシステムにまあする前にアビダンマ世界がクローズインされたということなんですね
いわゆるテーラワーダの世界では
その何でも早くクローズするという現象がありますから
変化できないようにとシールしちゃうんですね
だから だからこのシールしちゃうんです
だからこれはさらに人々が研究する前にシールしてしまったんじゃないかなと思いますね
だからこのお釈迦様亡くなってもう三ヶ月間になったところですぐ経典にはシールしちゃったんですね
もう触るなと 余計なことを言うなと
お釈迦様これおっしゃったのはこういうものやと
もう決めておいて それはもうそれから人々はまあそれには手を出すことはもう禁止
だから経典が新しく書くことは全くもう
もう想像もできないほどのもう仏法僧に対する侮辱なんですね
一言葉も変化させません
その通りにシールしてあって
ですから繰り返す経典とかね
まあいっぱいあります
そんなたくさん同じことを繰り返し言わなくてもいいんじゃないかなとかね
あるんだけど それはもうどうしようもない
もうシールしてる で それから問題になったのは注釈なんですね
注釈の場合は注釈だから
そのその先生が自分で注すればよろしいし
でもそれまた危ないんだと
人は好き勝手に自分で注釈しちゃうと
これは信頼できないんだと
自分の意見で悟った人の意見を注はできないんだ
悟った人は悟った経験から真理が分かっているんであって
そこら辺の人々はこれはこういう意味だよと言えるはずがないんですね
ですから 注できるのはやっぱり悟った人だけなんですね
それで経典に注入れる注釈入れる習慣というのは
お釈迦様から始めたんですね
お釈迦様も自分が厳密な何か言葉を言って
それからその言葉を分析して
こういう意味で こういうわけで
こういうことでこういうことを言ってましたよと注釈を入れるんですね
それで一番たくさん注釈を入れたのはサーリプッタ尊者なんですね
そういうのは全部このお釈迦様がいた時代で注釈を入れましたからね
そこでそれなりに大なる阿羅漢たちがそれなりに注釈を作ったりしましたし
それは全部お釈迦様はその通りですよと評価するんですね
で それであの勉強の過程になったところで
いろんな一人の人には全ての経典を勉強することは不可能ですから
それから仏教を守る過程では
みんな一部一部分けてもらって
私はこの部分は守っていきます
で 他の人は他の部分を守っていきなという風に学派が出てきて
それでその自分の自分が受け継いだ経典を大事に守っていくんですね
その中でもちゃんとした注釈も発展するんですね
まあそういうことで かなり膨大な注釈
恐ろしいほどの注釈量が出来上がったんです
そういうのもすごい昔の話で
その注釈 膨大な注釈発展したのは
まあ地理的にはスリランカで発展したんですね
で インドでもあったんだけど
インドよりはスリランカは仏教一色になりましたから
みんなすごい真面目に阿羅漢たちがね
で 仏教を守るということで
注釈っていうものはどんどん発展してあって
それで注釈は学派に分けてるんだから
量が大きいんだけど 同じ注釈はこちらもあって
あちらもあるということになっちゃうんですね
例えば長部経典を守っている学派と中部経典を守っている学派を見ると
経典ではもう似ている経典いっぱいありますからね
同じ内容の経典 全く同じ内容の経典があります
それで長部派の注釈がありまして
中部派の注釈もあるんですね
だから注釈を見たら同じ注釈ではないかと
そこで量は大きいんだけど
まあかなり同じ言葉を繰り返して繰り返して注釈を入れるようにもうなってしまったんですね
とにかくその注釈は全部この昔の人々の言葉であったんです
いわゆるそのスリランカの島の人々は同時に使っていた言葉
いわゆるシンハラ語ですけどね
全部注釈あった 注釈はパーリ語であったってもあまり意味がないんです
このパーリ語でわからないんだから注釈するんだから
自分の言葉で注釈してあったんですね
それからこの四世紀なんですね
全部注釈パーリ語になったのは
四世紀になったところで
このやっぱり仏教は国際的な宗教だから
テーラワーダ仏教っていうのはスリランカ人だけやってるわけじゃなくて
インドにもいっぱいいましたし
で 他の国でもいましたし
それはみんなのためにならなきゃいけないんだと
ということで インドから来たブッダゴーサ長老が全部注釈をパーリ語にしたんですね
パーリ語にする場合は一人でやってるんだから
同じことをダブってダブって繰り返し繰り返し書く必要はないんだから
すべての注釈を見ながら
経典にちゃんとほとんどダブらないように
注釈書を新しく書いたんですね
パーリ語で そのパーリ語で書いたものは
世界的に上座部仏教の注釈書として認めるようになってしまったんですね
それっきりであの昔あった歴史的な注釈っていうのは全部消えちゃったんです
ものすごい量あったんだそうです
全部それっきりで消えちゃったんですね
残っていたならば大変な勉強になるはずなんですけどね
仏教の内容というよりはね
その人々の考え方やら当時の社会関係やら
特に言語のね 言語というのはどのように発展しているかとかね
例えば今私たちを喋っているシンハラ語と
この紀元前の時代の人々が喋っていることは全く同じわけじゃないんだからね
結構すごい違うんです
だからこの石なんかにいろいろ昔いろんなことを書いて彫ってますからね
今読んでわかりません
で 古く書いてるテキストとかね
古典ありますけどね そういうものも現代の人々にはわかりません
そういうものも大学とかでちゃんと国語を勉強しない限りはね
ですから 言葉というのはどのように発展したかとか
そういう研究とかはできなくなってしまったんだけども
だからこの印刷技術とかね
何もなかったんだからね
やっぱり手で書いて書き書き書かなくちゃいけないし
ずっと書き写す写しなくちゃいけないしね
まあ一旦便利なパーリの注釈書ができちゃったんだからね
それでなくなってしまったんです
いや それはまた全く関係ない別な話なんですけど
とにかくこのブッダガサ長老やら
もうその人々より随分昔
スリランカに仏教が伝わったその時代になると
もうアビダンマもパッターナというこのパッチへの説明
そういうのはもう封印されていたんだから
もう勉強はできますけど変化はできませんっていうことになったんじゃないかなと
ですからこのありますけど
そんなはないということだけ言いたかったんです
じゃあ一つ一つ説明勉強していきましょう
1番目はヘートゥパッチヤ
で こちらでは書いてないと思いますから
ヘートゥパッチヤは日本語で因縁ですね
だから12因縁とかなんとか言いながら
こちらのヘートゥパッチヤというのは因縁ですからね
この場合は因という縁という意味なんですね
ヘートゥというパッチヤですよ
だからこれ自体もいらないんですけど
ヘートゥとパッチヤが別々に分けている分けようと思っているところだから
いわゆる原因と条件を分けましょうという話だから
原因という条件ですよというと
原因イコール条件になるんですね
だからそれ自体も入れなくなっちゃいますね
結局はよく考えると原因と条件を分けましょうと
条件どれぐらいありますかというと
あ 原因という条件がありますと
という意味がないんです
結局  そういうことはそうなんですけど
こちらで何を考えてるかというと
原因自体が条件になりますと
ということなんです 原因そのものも一つの条件として見ているんですね
二番目はヘトゥパッキャよ
アーランマナパッキャと
アーランマナ アーランマナっていうのは対象ですから
対象ですね で アーランマナというのは決まってあって
ゲンニビセッシン対象がアーランマナなんですね
ゲンニビセッシンギの対象って何ですかというと
色声香味触法という六つですね
その六つにはアーランマナというし
対象というんですね だから対象があることを条件にするんですね
例えば聴覚が生まれたとする
自分-- 私には聴覚が生まれるためには
やっぱり音という条件がなければ聴覚が生まれませんと
だから音は原因でもあります
音の原因で聴覚が生まれる
こちらで音はまた条件にもしているんですね
まあそれも考えればなくてもいいんですけどね
音の原因で聴覚が生まれるといえば
それはそれだけのことだから
だからお釈迦様の時代では分けてないんです
だからこれ考えたっても
なんかちょっと強引ですね
音という条件で聴覚があります
色という条件があるならば
眼識というか そういう聴覚-- 聴覚じゃないんですよ
その場合は 視覚ですね
視覚が生まれる 考えてみればそれも要らないんだけどね
次にアディパティパッキャ
アディパティ これはテキストで主縁ですかね
主縁と訳しています アディパティっていうのは一応支配しているという意味なんですね
支配していることが条件になるんだと
それはどういう意味でしょうかね
それはこの様々な対象の中で支配しているものが-- ものを我々は認識するのです
で ここで我々は今授業をやっていますけど
このドアを開けて こちらに関係ない
全くもう一度も見たことがない
知らない人がさっと入ったとすると
皆様方は私がここにいるにも関わらず
私が喋っていることにも関わらず
その人のことを見て聞いたりする
その対象として その対象が支配しちゃうんです
見るものはほかにもあるのに
聞くものほかにもほかにもあるのに
一つ選んで聞いたり見たりするんでしょう
それはまあ主縁ですね